bounce ago and read my despair I wanted
to share a highlight from us playing
some Hunger Games it's pretty much a
survival game everyone's against
everyone in a huge map and Last Man
Standing so it's pretty funny
enjoy wait wait are you is it you guys
down there by the blue container
building looks like a warehouse I wonder
if I can make this jump I wouldn't do it
if I was you I'm wondering if I can make
this jump let's go down this way it was
work together how do I get off this why
would you build a crane that can't go
down gotta be careful okay hold on
terrifying breathing deeply okay I know
the weapon down here either
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm so [ __ ]
you see me plus you the lights whoa wait
I can see
who's running I think no no no I'm
hiding behind a house behind the ledge
I'm just being terrified it's go save
him let's go where are you where are you
I'm so scared
Nora Nora no sorry wet oh [ __ ] there I
am what's how am i doing there it is
let's go on a rescue mission yeah my
heroes are you guys walking on the
bridge right now yeah I can see you guys
far far off you guys see my Morse code
I'm stuck II are you guys gonna catch me
or what I don't know this is bad idea
promise to catch me this time okay
wide - holy [ __ ]
thank you for catching me with your face
he was inside me I took I am so sorry
turn around I don't watch it
what's up what just happened I'm scared
I'm scared I'm out of here
why sinned again oh [ __ ] yes a katana
shove all for the shovels
now we must kill minks no no shovel
power so much travel Power Shovel power
shovel boss
shovels now who's the ultimate shovel
master die you [ __ ] shovel [ __ ] I'll
[ __ ] you up [ __ ] shower only one can
be the master of the shower hell yeah
this kill I have ever ever got on anyone
in a video game body left in pieces
alright brother
hope you had fun watching this little
highlight if you did leave a like it
helps me out a lot
hit subscribe to become a bro today and
I'll see you
whoa you idiot vodka top man get off me
ugly [ __ ] [ __ ]